[Music]
hey guys this is cj with beamer tech and
i'm here with my bmw 535i f10 i know a
couple of people who have purchased
spare key fobs and don't know how to
quite get them programmed you call the
dealership and they tell you to either
bring it in or they flat out don't know
how to get it done well i'm here to show
you how to get it done in a few quick
and simple steps the first step is
basically unlocking your car door with
your existing key fob and getting in the
driver's seat
once within your vehicle you're going to
make sure that your existing key fob is
not with you you're going to take your
new key fob and locate the key markings
on the side of your steering column
once you've located the key markings
you're going to place your new key fob
on those key markings
with your other hand you're going to
start your vehicle
and that's it your new key fob is now
activated your idrive will prompt you to
select the name for the profile
associated with this new key fob you can
do this using your idrive controller
this will allow you to save settings
such as your seats steering wheel
mirrors and other personal driver
preferences you can pick up one of these
key fobs from beamer tech they're all
bmw original parts and they're designed
specifically for your bmw in mind for
more information please visit beamer
dash tech.net thank you for watching and
i'll see you next time
you